As we enter
year two of the
Russian invasion of Ukraine.
How united is the global community
against Russia?
Not as much as you might think.
Yes, the West's core coalition remains
remarkably solid.
But you get a sense of the big picture
when you look at this map
that was published in The Washington
Post, differentiating those countries
who have armed Ukraine or impose
sanctions on Russia.
And those that have not.
And yes, on Thursday, the U.N.
General Assembly approved
a nonbinding resolution
that calls for Russia
to end hostilities in Ukraine
and demands the withdrawal of its forces.
But while 141 countries voted in favor,
seven voted against, and 32 abstained,
as the New York Times
recently summarized,
instead of cleaving in two.
The world has fragmented
a vast middle seas.
Russia's invasion is primarily
a European and American problem.
Rather than view it
as an existential threat.
These countries are largely focused
on protecting their own interests
amid the economic
and geopolitical upheaval
caused by the invasion.
So against this backdrop,
have the sanctions
imposed by 33 countries been effective?
In a piece in Fortune titled
How the Russian Economy
Self-immolated in the Year
Since Putin Invaded Ukraine.
Jeffrey Sonnenfeld and Steven Tan of Yale
write the 1000
plus global companies
who voluntarily chose
to exit Russia in an unprecedented
historic mass exodus
in the weeks after February.
2022 have largely held true
to their pledges
and have either fully divested
or in the process of fully separating
from Russia with no plans of return.
Quote, These voluntary business
exits of companies
with in-country revenues
equivalent to 35% of Russia's GDP
that employ 12% of the country's
workforce were coupled
with the imposition
of enduring
international government sanctions
unparalleled in their scale.
And scope.
So the picture presented
is that it is really crippled
the Russian economy.
But in the same week, Gallup found this
sanctions failed to sour Russians
outlook on economy.
The poster summarizes more Russians
see economic conditions improving,
then getting worse.
Majorities across
all regions are satisfied
with their standard
of living, and regions
closest to the conflict
have seen huge
improvements in perceptions.
How can that be?
Joining me now
to discuss is Muhammad Yunus.
He's Gallup's
editor in chief and editor of The Week
in Charts.
Thanks so much for being here.
First of all,
how can you get accurate polling data
from Russia?
Well, we've been polling across
Russia now for 15 years.
It is not as hard as you think,
but it's certainly not easy.
And it's part
of what we've been building
since 2005 called the Gallup World Poll.
And it's where we have
now quantified
the voice of 98%
of the world's population.
So we've been very hard at work
throughout this conflict
trying to quantify people's voices
both in the Ukraine but also in Russia.
In the United States
and in neighboring countries.
What accounts for the relatively rosy
outlook on their economy
that you found among the Russian people?
Well,
I don't want to overstate the rosy
ness of the outlook.
Certainly,
Russia and Russians
have paid an enormous cost
both in loss of life and otherwise.
But perceptions of people's own
economic outlook
aren't as negative
as you would imagine, given
the also likely very accurate
and sound data
that you started this segment
with from economists.
I think this is why
giving people a voice in these
situations is so critical,
because it's easy
for either side to really fall
into the narrative
of what their view is
from the Western view.
As you mentioned,
Sanctions have been really a cornerstone
of that policy.
But if you look at some aspects
of the Russian economy,
say, for example, the value of the ruble
Certainly people's own assessments,
we don't see that pain, at least not yet
settling in on that popular level.
Mohammad, there's another
matter of perception
that that I'm now having my eyes open to.
I was under the belief
that the world is united against Russia,
that it's Russia
and a couple of rogue states,
you know, the usual suspects, Iran
and North Korea.
But the data that I pointed out
at the outset
in a great piece
that was published
in both The Washington Post
and another
in The New York Times
opened my eyes to the fact
that particularly
in the Southern Hemisphere,
it's just not the case.
You know, and the other thing
that recently happened
is the
G20 failing
to have a consistent communique around
the situation in Russia.
You're right,
the world isn't united
because the world is being impacted
in different ways.
One of the things we do
is track global hunger and also people's
assessments of their own
economic situations,
not just in Russia,
but across the global South.
And we absolutely see the pain
of inflation, of the conflict,
in particular
in countries
that are
really important grain importers
from Russia and Ukraine
seeing the pain of this conflict.
So from the perspective
of the rest of the world,
it looks at this conflict
in a very different light than the US
which is really looking
at it from the perspective of
the global order.
And the data
we just came out of the field with
I know you're going
to share really drives home
that point at least here in the US.
I'm going to be right.
We've we've spoken
about the perception of Russians.
We've talked about the global dynamics.
Let's put up.
Thank you for giving to us
the very latest
in terms of American perspective
and how folks here
are looking at the war.
What's the bottom line?
The bottom line is we continue
to see an uptick in Americans
viewing the conflict itself as
an important
or critical threat
to the vital interests
of the United States.
It started out about in the forties,
in the mid forties,
when actually the first round of
this recent
flare up between
Ukraine and Russia took place
several years ago.
But what's important to keep in mind,
Michael, is both here in the US,
in Russia,
resolve is really there
for a prolonged conflict
in the Ukraine, its highest of all.
And we talked about that
last time I was on the program.
So from a public sentiment perspective,
the critical populations to this conflict
seem to be preparing
for a much longer haul
than many of us had hoped when
the conflict started.